you mentioned Jason Whitlock uhhuh he
obviously another guy who has had a very
long career on TV he is also a very
polarizing film oh Big Time major you
guys did speak for yourself together y
um which I believe that was your first
that you guys started that show together
n Colin coward and Jason Whitlock
started it it was that's right it was
Colin and him yeah so you came in once
went and and just focused in on the
radio TV um what was it like working
with him because he has a lot of very
interesting opinions yeah a lot of
people say he's kind of like Uncle
Ruckus you oh yeah I've seen the memes
I've seen the memes manam you know like
he's seen them too um Whitlock is
Whitlock one thing about him you can say
whatever he is about what he believes
and what he says and that's what I like
now that doesn't mean he lives out all
of that I'm saying his opinion is going
to be unwavering unless challenged by
something greater right and I love that
I don't care how you get up to the top
of your mountain man there's so many
different paths um I'm not here to judge
in that respect but be you that's what I
love the most about him now what's tough
being with wilock is he's always going
to throw some extra hot sauce on no
matter what he says it could be the most
simple of takes he's going to put some
spice on it and at times I feel that's
unnecessary but that's how he serves it
so you got to either eat it or you going
to be mad at it you know and um I
remember when he first I worked with him
at ESPN a ton of times right and then we
he started coming over that careb he was
like yo your contract up you need to
come over here got this family style
show we're going to do kind of like The
Cosby Show for sports and you know
you're such a great father and what you
represent you're such a good dude and um
he was like I can let you have the
platform to do that now I'm coming off
Sports Nation which was which was great
shout out Michelle Beetle shout out
Michelle Beetle Max Kellerman Thompson
it a great show oh man Carrie Champion
LZ Granderson and that was part of the
point I could name too many damn
co-hosts right so here I go again I'm
going this way I'm going this way I got
so many teammates couldn't build up like
brand chemistry um but I loved it all I
love the experience and you know our
show was lighthearted personality it was
great it was a great show man oh yeah so
we had a ball but then he start talking
to me about this I was like it'd be
probably good right now to change it up
so I go over there and love my
experience over there to the fullest
only two things that really changed well
maybe three things that changed my whole
complexion of how that experience was
going was one the pandemic when the
pandemic hit you know everybody got
their feelings everybody starts separ
separating getting polarized and even
more than before more than before right
so I'm like damn I'm just trying to take
care of the kids make sure they they
ain't on the iPod and iPads 25 hours a
day you know way too much and um that
was part one part two was Whitlock left
you know kind of in the middle of the
night even though I had heads up I knew
people that knew his situation little
Disturbed he didn't tell me straight up
cuz then you cuz he convinced you to
come over right right so if if anything
is percolating right you're supposed to
let me know give heads up I agree Max
kilman did that with First Take day one
he was like hey dog what you think I'm
thinking this talk through it not like I
got the overall decision making no but
it's it's it's a courtesy right and I
didn't get that with wh like I had to
know it and then just had to see him
every day then finally he dipped and I
was like oh that's that was real then
all good but he left and that kind of
left the imprint on me like uh all right
this thing ain't like the team you think
this is which I kind of knew already but
it got hit in the face again and the
last thing was my agent left um my agent
was a super agent too still my homie um
still the man Nick Khan who went to
WWE now he runs WWE and he basically
told me on the way out he was like look
he had a ton of clients he was like look
man every now and then you got to swing
for the fences and he's like I've been
hitting a lot of base hits Doubles
Doubles inside the park home runs like
like he was killing it no one thought he
probably from the outside should left
but now he's running WWE I think billion
dollar company thank you that part so
you know he was just like you gotta
swing for the fences and that was a seed
that was planted that didn't Blossom
until my contract was up and I was like
damn I'm just feeling all that so long
story short working with Whitlock it was
great it was the challenge was not us
doing the show it was people hear him
and didn't hear me so you know we do a
segment even though I'm challenging them
or supporting them they didn't hear me
they heard Whitlock cuz he got the
spicier of the takes yeah I'm I'm not a
debater I'm a discusser I'll talk long
I'll talk strong yeah he's going to say
the crazy highlight the stuff that gets
clipped and puts on Twitter and right
and that was challenging because that's
not who I am I'm not based like that I'm
listening to all perspectives to grow A
New Perspective and I just got a little
fatigued to that but I still was going
to roll with it because I really cared
about the show and I really like what we
were doing do you feel like at times
like would you ever run into any
uh issues when he would take a position
on something oh yeah a ton and you're on
the show with them so do you get
associated with that or they like yo fam
like what are you doing like yeah he was
saying some of the Kaepernick [__] I I
don't know if that timeline lines up
with speak for yourself but just some of
the things he was saying about cap and
[__] where I was just like yeah yeah you
know it was just like a little like
offputting I guess to hear that on like
you know I I I I again even like you
know we talk about him leaving and doing
his own thing but hearing that on like
ESPN or Fox at the time kind of crazy
some of the things he was saying yeah
and you know without particulars like um
Kaepernick was a hot button issue I
didn't mind that because you know I I
don't even know how you say this
properly but uh I had my issues with
Kaepernick as well but no I think I
think I think as the way you say it well
I think as it kind of the cap thing I
think as it wavered and I it felt like
he really had real opportunities I I
think that that Atlanta thing that
happened where he had the workouts and
he wanted to do the workout his way I
was like bro they're giving you the yo I
mean I I people have come up to me and
literally said can I talk to you for a
sec I I'm sorry I apologize I don't even
know these cats I thought you were
sellout I thought you were against us
and all that and I was like dog I don't
even believe in all that stuff you're
talking about I just tell you what I see
from my perspective and my experiences
on any situation I knew Kaepernick
before all that uh I haven't talked to
him since but I saw the 180 fine you
know I see that ain't the first I guess
for me it was just like the demonization
of someone just kneeling to bring
attention to something obviously you get
into three or four years later down the
road the lawsuit like he cashed out you
know what I'm saying and then he still
had an opportunity to play see that's
that's the point though this is the
funny I I always tell people I am not a
hater right I just tell the truth too
early and I've said it way like day one
I'm like can read this like it's like if
you take me to a workout and show me
some defensive ends I need three reps I
can tell you who this and who down here
that fast so I read the situation
accurately um from that moment doesn't
mean he's not doing work but you said it
best he he brought attention but I don't
think the attention was going where
everyone thought it was going a lot of
it was coming back to be self-serving
but he's still doing the work I ain't
even mad at him but I was just like yo
this ain't gonna go like y'all think
it's going the way and the first play he
could have had was challenge the NFL not
be adversarial but challenge the NFL to
do exactly what he wanted but what did
he want he didn't know that's why he
didn't do any q&as he didn't go out
there didn't do a lot of interviews
didn't do any podcasts you mean a lot
you mean none none and also took that
money and and didn't say any I mean I
mean we don't know how much it was right
no but I'm sure the condition of him
getting that money was everything
is yeah if the NFL of course you're
going to make him sign the NDA of course
you're going to say you can't go out
there and damage our brand but hey act
like you want to play every single year
and that's what you said it's like if he
really really really wanted to still
play I feel like that that Atlanta thing
the way he moved the workout last minute
on purpose I was just like people act
like this just happened at that point I
was like guys okay we got to like and
you a couple years after me when I was
like guys yeah no I was I was for sure
cuz it took me a while but when that
happened I was like like I this is this
ain't it what's going on well you know
what's going on and it's just funny
because I know too many guys that would
die for a workout like I know dudes that
are beasts Ballers give me a workout dog
that's rap it's on and this guy had
multiple chances and opportunities and a
workout and a settlement and y'all
trying to act like they trying to keep
him down maybe you don't want to get up
that's how I looked at it and it wasn't
that deep for me people act like he was
the Lord and Savior I'm like no
government nobody out here is saving you
from your world because if it works or
it doesn't work you still got to do the
work you do the work and so I'm like why
did everyone get so wrapped up in that
it was kind of crazy but to your point
Whitlock and I agreed like this ain't it
right but he agreed in a way where
people are like damn dog and I got kind
of caught up in a little of that right
right right right right but I did my
part two I did my part two